y ellos me enseñaron el sentido del humor.
Mi personalidad cambió y pasé de ser tímida y torpe
a ser desafiante y maldecir como un marinero.
No hace falta decir que no tenía muchos amigos.
Era hipersensible a las texturas.
El agua sobre mi piel me daba una sensación de hormigueo
y por eso, durante años, me negué a ducharme.
Les aseguro que ahora mi higiene ha vuelto a los niveles normales.
(Risas)
Tuve que trabajar mucho para llegar hasta aquí y mis padres...
las cosas se salieron de control
cuando fui agredida sexualmente por un compañero,
por lo cual, una situación ya difícil empeoró aún más.
Viajé más de 3000 kilómetros y atravesar el país para recibir tratamiento
y a pocos días después de que me recetaran un nuevo medicamento,
mi vida se convirtió en un episodio del Walking Dead.
Me volví paranoica y empecé a alucinar
viendo cadáveres putrefactos que se me acercaban.
Mi familia finalmente me rescató,
pero para entonces, había perdido 9 kilos en esas tres semanas,
además de haber desarrollado una anemia severa
y estar al borde del suicidio.
Me trasladaron a un nuevo centro de salud donde entendían mis aversiones,
mi trauma y mi ansiedad social,
y sabían cómo tratarlos, y recibí por fin la ayuda que necesitaba.
Y después de 18 meses de duro trabajo,
pasé a hacer cosas increíbles.
Una de las cosas que pasan cuando uno tiene Asperger es, que muchas veces,
estas personas tienen una vida interior muy compleja,
y lo sé de primera mano: tengo una personalidad muy exuberante
estoy llena de ideas y tengo un montón de cosas en la cabeza.
Pero hay una brecha entre donde ocurre todo esto
y cómo lo comunico al resto del mundo.
Y esto puede hacer de una comunicación básica un desafío.
Pocas empresas estaban dispuestas a contratarme,
debido a mi falta de habilidades sociales,
razón por la cual presenté mi solicitud en Waffle House.
(Risas)
Waffle House es un restaurante excepcional abierto las 24 horas
(Aplausos)
--gracias--
donde puedes pedir tus patatas fritas de las mismas numerosas maneras
en las que también te puedes deshacer de un cadáver humano...
(Risas)
en rodajas, a dados, sazonadas, en trozos, recubiertas, rebozadas, o ahogadas.
De acuerdo a las normas sociales
solo hay que ir a Waffle House a horas intempestivas de la noche.
(Risas)
Así que una vez, a las 2 de la mañana,
estaba charlando con una camarera y le pregunto:
"¿Qué es lo más ridículo que te ha pasado en el trabajo?"
Y me dijo que una vez entró un hombre completamente desnudo.
(Risas)
Le dije: "¡Fantástico, me apunto para el turno de la noche!"
No hace falta mencionar que Waffle House no me contrató.
Padecer de Asperger puede ser visto como una desventaja,
y a veces es un asunto realmente desagradable
pero también puede ser una ventaja.
Es un regalo, y me permite pensar de manera creativa.
A los 19 años, gané un concurso de investigación
con mi trabajo sobre los arrecifes de coral,
y llegué hasta la Convención sobre la Diversidad Biológica de la ONU
para presentar esta investigación.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Y a los 22, estoy a punto de terminar la universidad,
también soy cofundadora de una empresa de biotecnología llamada AutismSees.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Pero veamos lo que tuve que hacer para llegar hasta aquí:
25 terapeutas, 11 diagnósticos erróneos, y años de dolor y trauma.
Pasé mucho tiempo pensando si hay una forma mejor,
y creo que es la tecnología de apoyo para el autismo.
Esta tecnología podría desempeñar un papel fundamental
para ayudar a las personas con trastornos del espectro autista, o TEA.
La aplicación Podio, lanzada por mi compañía AutismSees,
tiene la capacidad de hacer evaluaciones independientes
y ayudar a desarrollar habilidades de comunicación.
Además de esto, hace un seguimiento del contacto visual a través de una cámara
y simular un discurso o una entrevista de trabajo.
Así que tal vez un día, Waffle House me contratará
después de practicar más con esta aplicación.
(Risas)
Y una de las cosas geniales es que he usado Podium
para preparar la charla de hoy, y eso me ha ayudado mucho.
Pero es más que esto. Se puede hacer mucho más.
Para las personas con TEA...
se ha especulado que muchos científicos innovadores,
investigadores, artistas, e ingenieros lo padecen,
como, por ejemplo, Emily Dickinson, Jane Austen, Isaac Newton y Bill Gates
son algunos ejemplos.
Pero se enfrentan al problema
de que a menudo no pueden compartir estas ideas brillantes
si la comunicación es un obstáculo.
Por eso, muchas personas con autismo están siendo infravaloradas cada día
y su potencial no se está aprovechado.
Así que mi sueño para las personas con autismo es cambiar eso,
eliminar los obstáculos que les impiden tener éxito.
Una de las razones por las que me encanta soñar con los ojos abiertos
es porque me permite ser libre,
sin ser juzgada o sufrir consecuencias sociales o físicas.
Cuando estoy volando en el entorno que puedo crear en mi mente,
encuentro la paz.
Nadie me juzga,
así que puedo hacer lo que quiero, ¿saben?
Salgo con Brad Pitt, y a Angelina no le molesta.
(Risas)
Pero el objetivo de crear tecnología de apoyo para el autismo
es más grande que eso y más importante.
Mi objetivo es cambiar la opinión de la gente sobre el autismo
y de los que sufren de formas avanzadas de Asperger
porque es mucho con lo que pueden contribuir.
Quiero decir, veamos a Temple Grandin, por ejemplo.
De esta manera, la gente puede compartir sus talentos con este mundo
y ayudar al mundo a mejorar.
Además, les alentamos a que persigan sus sueños
en el mundo real, en tiempo real.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)